[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
paepe nouveau jour de rentrée et on va
parler de l'actualité on va parler de la
réforme de la loi travail évidemment
dont nous avons maintenant connaissons à
peu près ce que sur les ordonnances on
va parler d' emmanuel macron grande
interview dans le point et baisse dans
les sondages tout cet été on va parler
aussi de l'europe parce que c'était le
sujet d'actualité des jours qui viennent
et pour en parler vincent couronne
bonjour je vous êtes enseignant à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
vous êtes peu fondateur du mouvement des
surligneurs c'est à dire que vous
regardez ce qui se dit dans l'actualité
et quand ce que nous avons c'est fou
notamment sur le plan juridique vous le
soulignez exactement florence père
cadets pour jour avocate au barreau de
versailles le specis de droit du travail
alors vous avez beau c'est que dis-je
est surligné toutes les ordonnances par
le premier à devoir philippe pénicaud
session de travail
donc nous en parle et stéphane minson
bonjour toujours enseigné enfin vous
êtes presque passage par entraide à vous
rendre et je le conseille vous avez
presque retraité non salées retraite
chez nous tout 65 et 68 ans encore non
oui c'est vrai ce qui les rend très vive
et enseignants donc vous allez faire
votre rentrée oui oui mais les vacances
commencent patrice vous savez que nous
autres universitaires travaillant
pendant les vacances et chacun le sait
comme tout bon fonctionnaire nous ne
faisons rien à partir de septembre à
juin
vous avez travaillé beaucoup pendant
sept oui
oui beaucoup peut-être aux éditions la
joie ni d'ailleurs toujours sportivement
lajoinie dont le pdg est ici et qu'ils
appellent cela dit bonjour on chantait
on va peut-être commencer par cette
actualité qui échoue depuis ce que
c'était jeudi à midi que le premier
ministre edouard philippe et la ministre
du travail mme héry alpini compte
annoncer ce qu'il y avait dans les
ordonnances pour la réforme de la loi
travail
bah je vais commencer avec eux avec vous
france mais recalé vous avez regardé un
petit peu à l'arrière il ya évidemment
plusieurs chapitres me regardait
profondément il ya plusieurs chapitres
qui courent attendait alors il ya
notamment cet équilibre entre ce qui va
se passer dans l'entreprise et ce qu'il
va se passer dans les branches
oui alors ce qui est intéressant dans la
date dans l'esprit dans les wii non
mieux pour répondre directement à votre
question oui là je pense que les
syndicats sont plutôt tous et ils sont
contents ils sont contents sur cet
aspect là je rends faire sur cet aspect
là bien sûr sur le renforcement des
branches puisque à l'origine et au
démarrage de la concertation le projet
était de plus tôt de vider un peu les
branches et de remettre certain nombre
de sujets au coeur de l'entreprise et de
pouvoir les soumettre à des accords
d'entreprise or c'est là où on voit que
la concertation a servi quand même à
quelque chose et ce qui d'ailleurs est
reflétée dans les réactions des
syndicats sur la partie conservation en
tant que tel où ils sont tous
unanimement ils compris la cgt en disant
oui il ya eu une vraie concertation à
vue 48 ou serre contrairement à ce qu il
y avait qu à l'enrayer la loi elle comme
rivalité de catastrophe
certaines lois antérieures également là
ils tous reconnaissent qu'à une vraie
concertation et la preuve c'est que la
copie d'origine est plus la même
à la sortie donc
là on a un vrai renforcement des
branches avec deux sujets qui sont
rajoutés aux branches qui sont la
gestion du rat prochainement un contrat
chez orange qui sont le cdd alors pas du
tout la problématique des motifs de
recours aux cdd qui reste dans la loi en
revanche les branches vont pouvoir
ajouter à la loi sur le nombre de
renouvellement des cdd de la durée etc
mais ce sera au niveau de la branche est
également sur un certain nombre de
sujets sur les cdi surtout sur des cdi
de chantier ou de missions qui vont
relever de la branche et non pas de
l'accord d'entreprise et des sas de
mission et saas avec les ssii a tant
séduit dans ce pour une durée les
perdants
voilà pour la durée d'une mission il
existe dans un certain nombre de
conventions collectives notamment dans
le bâtiment et pour certains un sujet
d'export ou de recherches ont donc là ça
va être peut-être généralisé sur
d'autres secteurs d'activité mais ce
seront aux branches de négocier cette
problématique là ensuite là où il ya un
aspect aussi qui est intéressant sur les
sur les branches
c'est que le constat c'est que 95% des
entreprises sont des entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés et 55% des salariés
travaillent dans ses enfants ses petits
dans ces tpe
donc au niveau de la branche
les dirigeants de ou représentantes tpe
et de pme vont être conviés aux
négociations ce qui n'existait pas avant
alors qu'il n'y était pas il n'y était
pas avant donc là va y avoir quand même
une ouverture et à un approfondissement
des branches qui peut être intéressant
là va y avoir une restructuration parce
qu'il ya un nombre de branches
absolument invraisemblable donc on va
restructurer pour diminuer le nombre de
branches
on va couper des branches voilà pas
fusionner des branches plutôt filons la
métaphore donc voilà
c'est au niveau de la branche c'est
plutôt satisfaisant pour pour les
syndicats et cela sans pardon c'est
intéressant pour les gens qui
travaillent dans des petites gâteries
que du coup et votre alors il ya deux
choses
c'est vraiment une loi enfin sadc pour
cor unum et les ordonnances sont
vraiment adapté au monde de tpe et des
pme
toujours sur le sujet des branches les
branches vont devoir faire des accords
cadres puisque les entreprises les tpe
les pme vont pouvoir faire des
négociations au delà de 50 salariés il
faut forcément négocier avec un syndicat
pour faire des accords d'entreprise et
en dessous de 50 salariés les
entreprises si elles ont des délégués du
personnel monde devront négocier les
délégués du personnel
donc ça s'est présenté en baisse de plus
de onze salariés et pour les entreprises
de moins de onze qui n'ont pas de
délégué du personnel
elles pourront faire une concertation
avec avec leurs salariés
donc ça veut dire que pour ses petites
entreprises elles pourront trouver des
accords type d'entreprise au niveau des
branches dont clément jeu vont devoir
faire un travail rédactionnel clair sur
lesquels elles vont pouvoir se baser
dans le cadre de négociations aussi bien
les délégués du personnel que les chefs
d'entreprise pour pouvoir négocier au
niveau de l'entreprise sur certains
sujets et pas sur tous puisqu'il y en a
qui seront ce sera la loi et d'accords
de branches quitte pas l'entreprise est
ce qui justement une modification des
instances de représentation du personnel
découvrez alors voilà il regroupe en
touche pas au seuil à partir de 11 ses
délégués du personnel à partir de 50
c'est le comité d'entreprise et le
comité d'hygiène et de sécurité chsct
depuis la loi rebsamen 2013 on avait la
possibilité jusqu'à un seuil maximum de
300 salariés de fusionner les trois
instances
donc ça ça existe déjà donc je trouve
qu'en termes de communication les
syndicats on a l'impression que c'est
quelque chose de tout neuf et que ça
n'existait pas auparavant ce que ça
existait jusqu'à 300 salariés et glane
au delà 300 c'était possible par accord
d'entreprise avec majoritaire maintenant
ça s'appelle le cso conseil social et
économique qui va s'imposer c'est à dire
que c'est fini
ce sera parce qu'on a la possibilité
d'en rebsamen c'était on pouvait
maintenir les instances les trois
instances où on pouvait enfin le nez 2
tous les trois ont dit que maintenant
c'est uniquement comme un comité social
et économique qui va être mis en place
donc il y aura plus d'un côté les
délégués du personnel l'autre côté le
csa tout va être fusionnée de manière
obligatoire donc ça s'appelait un peu
moyennement au syndicat puisque ils vont
perdre des creuseurs ils vont perdre un
certain nombre de de pouvoir même si
dans les faits on voit bien que certains
délégués du personnel avaient également
la casquette comité d'entreprise est
également la casquette comité d'hygiène
puisqu'il pouvait vous pouvez les cumuls
et donc ça va changer
forcément grand chose mais on était
quand même très atypique sur plan
européen puisque dans tous les autres
pays européens il n'y a qu'un seul lieu
de négocier de négociations donc on
revient on s'aligne sur la norme très
bien sûr fois c'est une simplification
qui me paraît quand même assez
raisonnable alors autre sujet qui
faisait des passes à l'indemnisation du
chômage non pas du chemin de
l'indemnisation de licenciement en
profite parce que c'est vrai que
certaines condamnations du prédame
pourrait indemniser le chômage
oui niveau de condamnations qu'on
pouvait avoir alors là c'est la
philosophie de ce parce que c'est ça ça
orthez beaucoup les syndicats la
philosophie de ce de ce barème qui est
un barème impératif qui n'est plus un
barème indicatif tel qui résultait des
lois antérieures c'est un barème
impératif il n'y a plus de plancher d'un
an le code du travail aujourd'hui
vous aviez un plancher de 6 mois de
salaire à partir du moment où
l'entreprise avait plus de onze salariés
que le salarié réclamé afin que le
salarié demandeur à des
dommages-intérêts avait plus de deux ans
d'ancienneté il avait obligatoirement
six licenciements étaient déclarés sans
cause réelle et sérieuse
six mois de salaire d'office ce plancher
à sauter donc il n'ya plus de plancher
et les indemnités sont
un mois de salaire par année
d'ancienneté avec un plafond à 20 mois
sachant que le barème indicatif
antérieures qui n'était qu'en dit katif
aller de 1 à 19 mois juste un mois de
plus 7
cette mesure va me semble assez bonne
parce qu'elle répond à deux contraintes
premièrement un problème de visibilité
pour le pour les chefs d'entreprises
puisque selon s'il se prend les pieds
dans le tapi dans son licenciement et
que son licenciement il déclaré sans
cause réelle et sérieuse il n'a aucune
visibilité sur aujourd'hui sur le
montant des condamnations qu'il va
supporter et c'est aussi une visibilité
pour les salariés parce que les salariés
selon qu'ils vont s'adresser au conseil
des prud'hommes de nanterre de la vie
néons de dunkerque y avait des
différences incroyables en fonction des
alors avec un dossier l'équivalent
préjudice et 10 valenciennes est
équivalente et est âgée qui valent ans
donc c'est qu'il y avait un peu d'une
absurdité dans ce système qui fait que
ça donne de la visibilité pour tout le
monde donc on a un plafond à 20 mois ça
fait 30 ans d'ancienneté et 20 mois on
sait que maintenant plus le temps va
passer - les gens vont avoir une très
grosse ancien il est rare de faire
vraiment
man 10 15 ans dans la même entreprise
c'est ça devient de plus en plus rares
donc ce que j'analyse là dessus c'est
que aujourd'hui quand un employeur va
prendre une décision de licenciement il
va bien évidemment avoir une visibilité
du risque qui est là et ça va pousser
enfin à mon sens ça va vider les
conseils de prud'hommes de contentieux
parce que parce que avocat eh bien oui
je vais pousser mémé clients bien
évidemment les gosses me disant si vous
êtes pris les pieds dans la neige près
dit sensible j'ai probablement les
considérables
il ya déjà des améliorations sur la
durée je suis sur lui sur le stand
intervention enfin le temps du
traitement qui donne ça va améliorer le
temps de traitement dès lors qu'il ya
moins d'un mois il ya d'affaires de
police à bord de trois ans au maximum
alors ça c'est maintenant c'est la durée
pour que le salarié saisissent le
conseil des prud'hommes à quoi on dire
qu'aujourd'hui il a deux ans à compter
de son licenciement il a deux ans pour
saisir le conseil des prud'hommes
les ordonnances ont ramené un nom il
faut savoir quand même qu'avant 2007
nous étions à une prescription de 30 ans
et il avait 30 ans pour saisir le
conseil des prud'hommes
après il a eu cinq ans ensuite il a eu
deux ans et maintenant il a un enfant
alors au départ l'ordonnancé plus c'est
moi qui serais fait virer en 2006 il
pleut il pleut encore des mines annoncé
maintenant c'est deux ans aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'en tant que c'est pas
d'accord c'était la loi de 2013 qui a
ramené de 5 de cinq ans à deux ans les
gens donc et 2007 a enlevé la
prescription trentenaire qui est ou qui
est absurde gravement c'était parce
qu'on allait à cheval porte et
désignation donc là c'est un petit peu
terminée les peintres continue peut-être
un mot de 3 c'est vrai qu'on voit bien
l'esprit de tout ça c'est à dire que
c'est on est plus favorable à la
négociation dans tous les plans que à la
loi ou même coco juge ouimet l'art est
juste un point est ce qu a bien expliqué
le ministre
c'était de dire que la world le col la
loi aujourd'hui le code du travail
il a même passé comme ça mais voilà il a
commencé comme ça en me disant ça ne
protège pas parce que c'est
incompréhensible
donc ça ne protège pas les salariés qui
eux mêmes ne s'y retrouvent pas dans le
code du travail
ça ne protège pas les employeurs parce
qu'ils ne s'y retrouve pas non plus dans
le code du travail est donc l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'est d'insérer des gens
dans l'emploi qui ne sont pas dans
l'emploi donc le code du travail a
peut-être tendance à protéger les gens
qui sont dans l'emploi mais ne font rien
pour des gens qui sont à côté qui ne
sont pas dans l'emploi donc l'idée c'est
d'avoir que quelque chose de plus
peut-être de plus flexible mais qui
continue à protéger quand même les
droits des salariés
et même si on dit que le barème c'est un
scandale parce que le préjudice à doit
se prouver on applique l'article du code
civil
ça n'empêche que c'est aussi je pense à
un plus pour les salariés qui vont avoir
une vraie lisibilité en se disant c'est
pas si je sens bien à lens voilà c'est
un mois par année d'ancienneté et en
contrepartie il ya un doublement de
l'indemnité légale de
de licenciement qui était d'un cinquième
de mois par année d'ancienneté qui
passera rien car deux mois donc 25 % de
majoration sur la question justement il
ya peut-être d'autres des guerriers un
mot qui revient on parle beaucoup de
talent mais c'est d'égalitarisme c'est à
dire que l'égalitarisme c'est pas
d'égalité où on traite les gens par de
la même façon mais finalement ne les
traite pas ça finit par des pâtes faso
et là aussi c'est une faveur de
négociations plus de la négociation
plutôt que la loi la négociation plutôt
que le juge c'est ça la philosophie
oui oui c'est ça la philosophie il ya un
égalitarisme égalité c'est vrai que
c'est pas les traités de manière
identique des situations qui elles-mêmes
sont très peuvent être très différentes
ne conduit pas à l'éducation notamment
par exemple même conduire en ville et la
légalité sans qu'on tombe pour autant
dans des danses qu'on appelle faussement
ou ce qu'on appelait la discrimination
positive
on peut très bien éviter ce genre de
situation et puis il ya aussi à une
philosophie mais là qui n'est pas propre
à maquereau et à son gouvernement une
philosophie de simplification ça depuis
une des ordonnances innombrables
relative à la simplification du droit
des détenus n'était que je ne cesse de
dire aux étudiants lorsque vous voyez
texte intitulé planification et souvent
des textes très complexe en eux-mêmes et
parfois ses textes la rampe par le droit
plus plus compliquée encore et on le
florence le soulignait tout à l'heure
c'est que
un ensemble de dispositions à dispositif
juridique jour le code du travail qui
est censé assurer une protection ne l'a
surplus quand il devient illisible alors
souvient de votre ami bayrou a portant
sur un plateau de télévision le code du
travail français en le mettant le code
du travail suisse bon là c'était un peu
simplificateur 10 mai mais cela dit là
l'image a été assez forte et je voyais
j'avais en mémoire quand florence parler
de cela de la complexité de la règle et
c'est la moindre des choses c'est pour
pour être protégé il faut savoir quel
est le contenu de la règle et quand on
le connaît pas ce contenu ça devient
complètement ubuesque
les juristes même ont parfois je n'ose
pas dire souvent bien je dirais presque
souvent des difficultés à comprendre les
règles juridiques et plus grave les
magistrats ont parfois des difficultés
et encore plus quand il s'agit peut-être
de prud'hommes ne seront pas dégagés
alors sont pas des magistrats
professionnels mais après on appelle en
soutenant premiers noms mais certains
jeunes et jolies têtes les niveaux
différents de nom de jugement non pas
forcément
c'est aussi un appel pas forcément bah
oui on appelle ça oui c'est à dire que
nous déjà on est professionnel il ya des
moments là je suis je me heurte à une
difficulté sur la dernière loi sur la
réforme de l'inaptitude il ya un trou
dans la loi et je sais pas comment
conseillé mon client et de la doctrine
elle part dans tous les sens puisqu'elle
s'est pas non plus et injuste un blanc
il me manque un mot dans une phrase et
le problème c'est que nous on peut
encore s'abstint mais qu'un juge est
obligé de juger et donc de là c'est à
dire le droit même lorsque le texte à
nouvelle bande 4 y trouvera sur l'esprit
et ça a l'air très bien enfin nettement
avant même les explications très savante
de florence notre ami voir philippe a
été plutôt convaincant salaires
intelligemment mené etc
et puis moi j'ai une sorte de baromètre
c'est que dès que la cgt la france
insoumise dit que c'est pas bien avant
même de moi du coup je me dis ça doit
être intéressant c'est le premier truc
donc là déjà dans sa couronne oui ça ça
ça m'inspire une remarque dans la suite
de la suite de ce qui a été dit juste
avant sur la simplification c'est que
ces ordonnances ont pour but de
simplifier aussi le droit du travail
mais en réalité quand on ouvre au code
du travail
si les tp c'est qu'il ya des articles
mais il ya aussi des décisions de
justice qui font jurisprudence à
l'intérieur qui vont prier
l'interprétation est question les
articles met en oeuvre on des articles
du code du travail ou alors simplifions
des éléments du droit du travail et
redonnant aux entreprises aux branches
soin de déterminer elle même certaines
règles en fait on complexifie encore
plus parce que salarié qui valait dans
une branche que dans une autre il n'aura
pas les mêmes règles dans une entreprise
et puis dans une autre d'une même
branche n'aura pas non plus une règle
des secteurs d'activité dont tous les
salariés du même secteur d'activité
auront les mêmes règles une législation
uniforme permet aussi de deux en réalité
d'abord une irisation uniforme enfants
et dans ces cas là dans ces cas là qu'on
ne dise pas qu'on va simplifier leur
lieu de travail
on le change mais assumant la
complexification aussi nos sociétés et
parce que c'est louise et l'argent
facile et tout et tout les entreprises
de simplification du droit depuis vingt
ans trente ans voire plus
à chaque fois c'était en fait les
entreprises de modernisation de la
mutation bon simplement en fait on
simplifie pas en complexifiant
s'adaptant à la moderne s'adapte voilà
hélas positifs dont j'ai pas parlé mais
qui est intéressant c'est le code du
travail numérique est alors sur cette
semaine une espèce de plateformes je
pense de ce que j'ai compris dans lequel
vous rira le code du travail mais
surtout aussi bien les salariés que les
employeurs pourront poser des questions
ils ont des réponses comme un espèce de
blogs géantes c'est un fait le numérique
du travail c'est un code numérique du
tricolore du travail numérique ou un
code numérique du travail je sais que
c'est pas un code du travail qui
s'intéresse à l'amérique doit ratisser
la ville du très bon sens je vais
refaire la version d'amérique du code et
nous broie les actionnaires du numéro du
travail sur une plate forme conclut me
king qui ai eu mes risques qui est
numérisé et donc les personnes qui iront
pourront avoir accès donc au code du
travail
mais pour ont surtout posé des questions
disant juste une telle situation
donc je tonds seulement je parle
contentieux jeu par le conseil ah oui
paris oui c'est l'armée qui répondra que
l'agencé ben voilà vous avez encore de
beaux jours et les avocats des deux
conseils des blues à vocation ça devrait
être probablement lié au ministère du
travail cissé ministère du travail à
dire un mot sur les une origine sur la
réaction alors
c'est assez intéressant parce que fo et
plus tôt alors plutôt favorable enfin ne
se pose pas de front à la réforme
la cfdt y avait habitués plutôt être
négociations se dit déçue la cgt appelle
à manifester ce qui est plutôt dans sa
vie vous vous explique comment ces
sortes de changements entre fo et la
cfdt est ce que c'est parce que la lcf
d'état gagner les élections il faut se
dit tiens c'est peut-être comme ça qu'on
va maintenant qu'à les syndicats
majoritaires à la faut qu'elles soient
aussi un peu contestataire donc c'est un
peu son rôle à aller jusqu à l la
contestation de la cgt mais bon je pense
qu'elle a ce rôle à jouer
mais là où elle explique elle exprime sa
déception c'est sur le sur un certain
nombre de sujets d'accords d'entreprise
qui lui échappe mais en même temps on
lui dit mais très bien mais dans 95
pourtant dans un certain nombre de 95 66
vous n'êtes pas présent
donc la thur horreur du vide donc à
partir quand vous n'êtes pas là ça
laisse à vous at il pas plus de choses
pour les syndicats agréés impression va
pas plus de choses pour les syndicats et
surtout sur les le zonage entre
guillemets un licenciement économique
sur ces mots que les licenciements
économiques auparavant quand on était
dans un groupe il fallait démontrer que
les difficultés sont au niveau mondial
mais maintenant ça va là c'est parce que
vous national néanmoins s'il ya une
fraude sociale fraude cette fraude
après le juge peut décider quel rôle
mais j'ai la scène mondiale
au niveau du groupe la cfdt dit de ce
que j'ai pas le tri au plus haut niveau
national d'accord mais avant de
prononcer de licenciements il faut qu'on
soit informé et consulté au niveau des
syndicats et des représentants du
personnel pour qu'on nous démontre la
réalité de la difficulté purement
nationale et que ce n'est pas mondiale
ce départ ce n'est pas une autre phrase
un groupe qui charge
c'est une entreprise qui est en
souffrance en mai contre syndicats pour
la il entendre je crois que leur
déception c'est de dire ce qu'on
demandait c'était pas ça peut rester
nationale mais ce qu'on demandait c'est
qu'il y ait une concertation en cours
nous démontre que c'est bien national
jégo nous mettre des documents sur la
sur la baie des veys cela la banque de
données économiques et sociales et pour
nous démontrer cela donc c'était bien
dans la concertation donc ça reste bien
dans la philosophie de ce que voulait le
gouvernement donc on comprend pas
pourquoi nous a pas donné satisfaction
sur ce point là et qu'il ya alors il y
avait un mot qu'on prononce depuis
quelques temps c'est la flexisécurité
c'est à dire que apporter aux
entreprises un peu de flexibilité et de
visibilité aussi dans dans leur gestion
mais un peu plus de sécurité aux
salaires il sait ce qui se dit nord
notamment
est ce que le compte est bon là dessus
quand on aura la région de la formation
professionnelle oui qu'est l'essentiel
qui est essentiel puisque la
contrepartie c'est ce qui se passe dans
l'aîné les pays nordiques c'est à dire
qu'il ya une facilité de licenciement
peut prendre une décision en l'espace de
dix minutes
mais en contrepartie le salarié se
retrouve immédiatement dans un processus
de formation professionnelle qui est
sérieux et donc le pendant de tout ça ça
va être la formation
c'est ce que disait l'ami de stéphane
jacques attali qui disait l'autre jour
alors lutter contre le sommeil c'est pas
faciliter les licenciements s'est formé
le summum il avait raison et il avait
raison
vous et vos amis sont bruyantes ou les
images que c'est une chance d'aimer mais
vous êtes notre ami jean autres
sur cette réforme vous voulez compressé
et dieu dans tout ça
oui d'être alors à la façon de chaque
chanson il n'a jamais dit vous avez aimé
il paraît que c'est un mythe
oui nature sera lui même disait qu'il
avait déposé en revanche il avait
demandé
je pourrais vous le bord des voiliers
stéphane manceau est ce que vous avez
déjà posé des conditions à la vie c est
ce qu on se croise alors on peut passer
mais on est on est dans le même sujet où
on a vu on va parler de la cote de
popularité de macro tout à l'heure mais
on voit qu'il ya un regain quand même de
confiance notamment des entreprises et
c'était les diversités du d'été du medef
cette semaine vous y étiez c'est
beaucoup de patrons je vous propose de
regarder un sujet sur cette université
d'été après on reparle justement de
est-ce que la confiance est en train de
revenir
c'est une tradition ici dans les
yvelines depuis 19 ans le medef le
principal syndicat des patrons organise
son université d'été ici sur le campus
hec paris à jour josas mais concrètement
à quoi ça sert
sadc a informé a informé par les médias
parce que la presse vous êtes là la
presse est là ça donne le ton de ce que
veut faire le medef
et puis encore une fois je vis pour nous
adhérence à peine de rencontrer
d'échanger autrement que dans nos
commissions aux trop nombreux amants de
plus convivial
cette année sept mille cinq cents chefs
d'entreprise ont fait le déplacement
jusqu'aux yvelines pour assister à 12
conférences sur les thèmes de l'économie
de l'emploi et de la france des
rendez-vous qui ont permis aux
entrepreneurs de se réunir pendant 48
heures et des conférences qui sont
toujours intéressantes parce que l'idh
ouvrir l'esprit ouvrir le cerveau pour
écouter effectivement ce qui se passe à
droite à gauche est toujours intéressant
surtout quand des choses sont dites
importantes comme tout à l'heure sur les
contractualisations du travail qui sont
des sujets qui sont effectivement durant
ce moment qu'ils sont importants
mon volant tous ces choses là sont
importantes à écouter il n'y avait pas
que des entrepreneurs la sphère
politique a également graviter autour de
cette manifestation neuf ministres se
sont rendus ici à jour josas on peut
noter également la présence d'élus yves
binois je tenais à travailler avec le
medef 78 j'avais pas encore rencontré et
on a passé une partie de l'après midi
ensemble qu'elles semblent
d'entrepreneurs hier c'est essentiel de
créer une routine avec eux donc une fois
par trimestre on puisse se voir et qu'on
puisse challenge et les projets du
gouvernement les attendent sur le
terrain l'événement également permis aux
syndicats ouvriers de se faire entendre
lors de ce deuxième jour de l'université
d'été du medef une manifestation qui a
réuni plus d'une centaine de personnes a
été organisée nous avons rencontré un
acteur local et ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on le fait cette année c'est un peu
comme l'année dernière on est dans le
même contexte où l'année dernière
s'étaient la loi comme guy qui se
préparait aux cours d'été là cette année
c'est un peu particulier puisque il ya
là les ordonnances qui sont en cours de
rédaction sur la loi travail
prochain acte du rapport de force entre
les syndicats le patronat et le
gouvernement le 12 septembre prochain
avec la première grande manifestation
nationale contre la réforme du code du
travail
alors
on va parler de la laddh cote de
popularité de maquereau qui baisse dans
les sondages mais la conscience les clio
temps peut-être économiques sont en
train de se redresser mais la confiance
à l'air à l'air au rendez-vous mais
c'est ça qui le cpc macron dans les
sondages espère que pour l'opinion
publique plus des patrons sont contents
plus le peuple est mécontent de ce qui
est dit pas si les patrons second temps
c'est donc qui mène une politique qui
satisfait les patrons donc nous on n'est
pas content donc c'est une des
explications peut ne pas être content si
on ne donne qu'aux patrons non on peut
me laisser messi mais c'est aussi pour
ça je pense que je vais plus plus la
confiance qu'on monte plus les xss
acquis puis les palabres d'autant plus
qu'on n'a plus eu le corps aussi c'est
un peu schématique
je pense qu il le dit d'ailleurs dans
les intérêts du point plus de
l'impatience que du mécontentement c'est
la question que se posaient les gens je
crois c est ce qu il faut faire quelque
chose ou pas est ce que comme leurs
prédécesseurs ils ont annoncé des
réformes qui ne feront jamais cessé spa
il a pris un chien ça bouge sur la
confiance alors puisque vous étiez à
jouy en josas plutôt qu à
garges-lès-gonesse mais dont vous avez
senti
est ce que risque on sent qu'il ya une
confiance qui revient ou pas notamment
dans le patron ah bah oui merci
les employeurs que non et les études le
montrent en tout cas tous les chefs
d'entreprise que j'ai rencontrés ils
sont contents pour plein de raisons ils
sont contents parce que le carnet de
commandes se remplit parce que quand
même le motif de
essentiel de contentement donc un le
quart des termes on se remplit les
délais de paiement se sont réduits donc
ils rendent plus de trésorerie dont il
arrive bien bien à reconstituer leurs
marges
donc ça c'est depuis depuis mois dernier
trimestre 2016 et 2017 et va être une
année convenable on va pas dire que 1.6
de croissance et c'est le nirvana c'est
mieux c'est mieux c'est quand même très
belle et du coup le salon donc le fait
que la croissance revient avec lui au
coeur mais voilà mais bien c'est tout ça
et psychologique
c'est quand même très psychologique mais
à en europe club allemand ça va quand
même relativement mieux dans tous les
pays donc non il faut que le chômage
baisse puis je crois qu'il ya une grande
confiance parce que le mot de confiance
responsabilité et confiance sont les
deux mots dans marche donc est
d'ailleurs maintenant on les utilise un
bienveillance confiance et
responsabilité c sont des mots qui
reviennent fréquemment dans la bouche de
tous les politiques et la de la
confiance ça ça peut ça peut s'affirmer
je pense que il m'a qu'on l'a affirmé
les gens auront confiance
donc même si pour le moment alors là ça
y est il se passe des choses mais les
patrons même avant qu'on ait les
ordonnances avait confiance quand même
bruit que c'est plutôt bien oui le même
je crois quand même les conseillers de
de gattaz j'avais dit il faut pas aller
trop haut dans le sang ce gouvernement
ce que ça allait j'aimerais peut-être ça
va il y avait une optimiste
au travers de ces deux journées de
travail
alors grande interview de débat nous
vaincrons dans le point dans laquelle il
n'aurait pas été surpris sud pieter
staut artistique
je vous avais quand je vous avais parlé
vous aviez pris pour un farfelu et ses
bals où j'avais acheté l'ouvragé oublié
sur la plage du site super test
l'évidence vous voyez bien que ce que
demande d'aidé demandé peut-être une des
raisons de la chute de popularité c'est
que les gens se demander où est ce qu'on
va te le demande est d'autant plus que
c'est un gouvernement quel de nouvelles
formes c'est pas la droite ou la gauche
moussa bâ vous pouvez savoir à peu près
est ce que est ce que l'interview là et
pas un peu intellectuel
un morceau le sur le choix d'un magazine
de presse écrite sur le choix de décider
sur intellectuelle est ce que c'est
assez clair pour que les les autres ont
dû s'y retrouve
c'est bien parce que d'abord à une
époque où tout se passe en un minable
tweet là pour une fois c'est un
entretien de 22 pages je trouve ça c'est
exact
voilà c'est déjà une très très bonne
idée et des questions parfois difficile
voilà donc donc
donc c'est très bien après les lecteurs
du du poing seront pas dépaysés les gens
qui n'ont jamais lu le point vont
probablement pas si mais si si mais tant
mieux mais toute pression ce qui est
intéressant c'est c'est les explications
que tous les éditorialistes vont donner
et ce que les autres journaux vont en
extraire donc voilà c'est pour vous
répondre à votre question le choix du
point moi je trouve que c'est un très
bon choix quoi c'est pas c'était mieux
que d'inviter les séries tellement
réducteur le 20 heures de tf1 ou france
2 c'est sympathique mais bon c'est pas
facile
il a enfin pu dire des choses et
exprimer sa pensée dire où ils voulaient
aller fin je trouve que c'est vraiment
intéressant et ce texte auquel on peut
se référer après tout reste que fin de
pensée complexe complexe ça va pas dire
compliqué un complexe ça veut dire qu'il
n'est pas constitué d'un élément simple
un seul élément et on a raillé le fait
que alors c'est peut-être mal dit que ma
kron avait pensé trop complexe pour
l'interview habituel du 14 juillet moi
je trouve ça plutôt très bien qu'un
président de la république plutôt simple
à exprimer une pensée complexe parce que
la vie elle est complexe parce que les
solutions qu'on peut apporter aux
difficultés qui sont des difficultés
très concrète et très quotidienne vécue
par les français au jour le jour sont
elles mêmes des solutions complexes et
les élus ou les candidats qui considère
qu'on peut apporter des réponses
simplistes rapide à des problèmes
compliqués là pour le coup complexe
menthe le savent très bien donc
aujourd'hui ça bien qu'un président
exprime une pensée quant à la politique
consiste pas simplifié des saw 6 mai par
exemple à ce que les électeurs puissent
choisir
pas forcément mais il ya tout ce qu'il
faut pour simplifier celle-ci drôle de
la preste de la presse des journalistes
des autres élus des commentateurs des
critiques et s'est laissé bien de sortir
des propos de bistrot des trucs de
prendre un peu de un peu de hauteur
c'est quand même un peu ce qu'on attend
d'un président de la république avec le
team mélenchon et ses environs critiqué
aussi nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'il
s'exprimait pas forcément bien beaucoup
trop et qu' il n'avait aucune culture
extrêmement comment dire lacunaire en
tout cas littéraire en main donc là on a
un président d'un public a fait un peu
de philosophie qui lie
donc pourquoi ne pas c'est très
mitterrandien ce genre de choses si ou
pompidou lien je sais pas mais de mettre
la culture quand celle d'un message
politique
ça donne une humeur d'une dimension
peut-être qu'on peut railler la sur le
moment mais que que les français aiment
bien sans doute aussi par exemple athée
je pense qu'elle est voilà tout on parle
à sa hauteur ces diamants sans penser
que les autres sont des abrutis à qui il
faut dire les choses
direct et sans complexité je connais les
gens sont flattés plus ambitieux pour
assurer que tout le monde ne lira pas
l'intérieur on savoure et censément
entendre les commentaires sur presse
qu'il faudrait surtout pas c'est que
cette interview soit l'unique vecteur de
la parole présidentielle parce que c'est
très bien de s'adresser aux lecteurs du
point et de s'exprimer sur 22 pages dans
le point mais ça suffit pas il faut
aussi qu'ils puissent répondre à de
véritables questions et pas peut-être
moins philosophique et sur effectivement
le tout venant de sa politique parce que
il peut pas s'abriter juste at-il gens
voilà j'ai fait cet entretien j'ai donné
cet entretien on a mis quinze jours à le
réaliser à leur lire tout et police et
il n'y a pas un truc qui étudient dans
lequel on peut mettre un coin donc voilà
c'est très bien mais ce n'est pas
suffisant il faut aussi que de temps en
temps il s'exprime de façon plus plus
large et ça on attend un peu
il ya une grosse polémique alors tout
cet été c'était le jour j ce qu'ils
disaient oui il faut qu'ils changent il
faut qu'ils s'adressent aux journalistes
je vais utiliser cette vidéo risque
étant un peu vexé que le président de la
république ait décidé de ne pas vouloir
faire toutes les confidences que leur
faisait ses prédécesseurs moi je crois
pas car il y avait sept
cette impatience du duduk du peuple
parce que ils s'adressent désormais
sinon je pense pas été expliqué comment
expliquer un butin
ça c'est sûrement une impression mais la
passion des journalistes et défend la
corporation mais c'est aussi une
impatience du des français qui se disent
par exemple la presse après cette
pitoyable séquence avec l'armée
française et aucune explication il n'y a
rien du tout c'est à dire que il est
balayé les questions
oui mon temps c'était une explication
qui est la sienne avec la grippe c'est
le figaro le figaro à l'assaut des
salles dont le lobby des vendeurs
d'armes
d'accord mais c'est là où on aimerait
bien qu'ils aient un journaliste pour
lui répondre un peu à cette cette
attaque
donc ok dit les choses il a dit des
choses mais là ça manque un peu de
de renvoi vrai je dirais un peu les
limites de cette intervention dans le
point c'est un peu comme si je jouais au
tennis tout seul il envoie les balles
mais personne ne lui renvoie le doute
elle a fait les questions
donc voilà un peu ce qu'on peut michel
droit sans michel droit sans faire du
bien donc voilà ça c'est un peu dommage
mais sur les raisons de la baisse de la
popularité
vous avez des analyses l'armée c'est un
déclencheur on sait que c'est qu'on se
méfie toi et même temps une double une
séquence doublement pitoyable j'espère
que le pouvoir que le pouvoir civil
s'impose au pouvoir militaire c'est
pitoyable
de cette façon là je te trouve c'est sa
première vraie véritable faute à dire
que jusqu'à ce jusqu'à ce nom sait faire
que jusque là il avait réussi à redonner
à la présidence une certaine stature une
certaine hauteur il incarne bien le ce
rôle etc
il n'a pas fait d'erreur c'était bien et
puis tout d'un coup au delà on en
parlera sûrement tout à l'heure du fond
du problème sur l'armée mais la csu
cette attitude de presque 2 de petits
chefs de sous-officiers qui monte sur le
truc et je suis chef mais ça a un côté
ridicule quand on est président de la
république personne ne lui conteste et
sahil avait pas à monter comme presque
comme un roc indre et c'est moi le chef
et puis je veux pas que qu'on le discute
c'est ça c'est pitoyable ça donne une
image de lui après après son côté un peu
je suis dans un sous marin je me fais
l'hypothèse lui machin avait un côté on
a eu un peu un été avec lui pas martine
à la plage mais emmanuel
tel endroit il mène à l'hôtel ambre
c'est très sympa mais bon il n'est pas
besoin de dire emmanuel petit chef
stéphane oui il fallait rappeler une
évidence alors général de villiers était
très apprécié par le par le milieu par
le milieu militaire le général lecointe
l'actuel ces mallettes aussi aberrant
mais il
à mon sens il se devait président la
république de rappeler cette évidence au
titre de laquelle le président public et
le chef des armées au titre de laquelle
le les armées sont un outil au service
de la nation
les militaires doivent avant tout
obéissance à leur chef suprême qui est
un civil ne leur en déplaise et donc on
a salué l'attitude enfin certains ont
salué l'attitude soi disant totalement
digne du général de phily etc
je le trouvais relativement
il aurait pu s'abstenir de beaucoup de
choses il s'est exprimé devant des
parlementaires alors de surcroît à huit
clos tout ce temps tout en sachant
évidemment que le huis clos devant la
mission parlementaire est un des traits
relatifs aux faits oui extrêmement
réactif resterait mais j'ai trouvé la
suite ou la gestion comme on dit de la
suite de ces événements par le général
lui-même extrêmement critiquable enfin
par général en chef par le grand manitou
emmanuel macron d'aller humilier son son
général en chef a imité sa part été le
nom qu'elle patine il aurait été très
simple pour le général de ville et de ne
pas se faire humilier entente est qu il
n importe quelle entreprise face et
c'est le b à ba du management on
n'humilie pas son numéro 2 mais ne nous
a pas de l'entreprise devant cette
chance
non mais c'était pas le lieu c'était pas
la façon et ça libère enfin sur le
numéro pas la mort d'un désaccord non
non a dit en privé l'a dit je ne vais
pas me faire baiser mais s'il n'y avait
pas d'injures du débit du chef de l'état
pas du tout après on peut pourrait
discuter du fond très longuement sur
est-ce que emmanuel macron avait fait
des promesses qu'il n'a pas tenues
il a fait des promesses fait qui m'a
d'abord une issue ça c'est un vrai débat
mais sur la gestion même sauf que les
manuels main qu'on n'avait pas à
profiter de deux devant l'état-major de
fin 2-2 devant les plus hauts gradés de
l'armée de la la garden party qui est au
ministère de la défense
la veille du 14 juillet c'est
traditionnellement un endroit au
président de la république vient il va
saluer les troupes il fait un discours
totalement lénifiant dit rien casser
cette tradition juste pour venir dire je
suis le chef et lots qui va rentrer dans
le rang il va fermer sa gueule et ccc
d'une indélicatesse jamais dans l'amour
est vrai mais ça n'aurait pas tenu dans
les écossaises
c'est bon ça se passe à l'europe
est-ce qu'il ya peut-être ça aussi dans
la baisse de popularité c'est que le
président de république
institutionnellement on en a déjà
beaucoup parlé ici et au premier plan b
le fait que au fond il n'y a aucun
ministre qui soit un poids lourd dans ce
gouvernement communiste politique ou
très peu de mises politique ou un peu
âgé il le candide le son ne fait pas que
un premier quand même n'a jamais été
ministre avant que les gens qui nous
connaissent pas est ce que c'est pas ça
aussi qui explique cette impopularité
parce que tout lire tout lui retombe
dessus c'est à dire il n'y a pas de de
gens qui peuvent le protéger je suis pas
sûr parce qu'il ya quand même du polo au
gouvernement et à nicolas hulot quand
même il ya des gens comme jean yves le
drian simplement la concision non mais
me direz montée et puis ils ont un
certain certains accès aux médias mais
mais cet accès aux médias lors a été
fermé dès le début du quinquennat par
emmanuel macron qui a verrouillé la
communication knox là aussi il ya eu six
poids lourds il ya ils ne peuvent pas
vraiment s'exprimer librement mais à mon
avis la chute de popularité c'est pas
quelque chose de conjoncturel c'est plus
quelque chose de structurels sous la
vème république
c'était le cas avec nicolas sarkozy
c'est le cas avec françois hollande a
cette fois c'est pierre jacques chirac
c'était pire encore que son prédécesseur
à ce niveau là et après quatre mois de
baisse comme police et que je vis avant
aussi un ses deux pires sondages il
pourra un président d'un public depuis
début de la 5e et c'était parti pour
faire un don via papillonne on était
bien à chaque fois c'est pire il
s'approcha succès seulement ça sera pas
dramatique et mais tout simplement parce
que il ya aussi salades il vaut mieux
commencer par l'impopularité un peu con
si difficile de savoir les causes ça
dépend des causes de la popularité pour
savoir comment va être géré cette loi
travail
oui la rue et on va y avoir les
élections en allemagne derrière va y
avoir les propositions qui va faire sur
l'europe
mais ce que je voulais dire c'est que je
pense que son impopularité c'est un
moment donné où les français se sont
dits main son ami au pouvoir des gens
qu'on jamais gouverné notamment par
exemple vernement ils ont jamais
gouverner on a mis des députés qui ont
un peu pédaler pendant les scènes ici où
ils ont jamais été celle où ils sont
pour certains ils sont pas au niveau et
je pense que tout ça a fait un espèce de
mélange qui fait qu'il ya une chute
pendant pendant l'été mais moi je suis
très optimiste et je pense que ça va
repartir
et puis tout le monde en parle pour
brigitte en plus donc c'est l'arrêt
c'est qu'ils veulent la popularité de
marine est maintenant bien des maux
alors l'europe il ya deux sujets il y a
les réformes institutionnelles que
voudrait introduire emmanuel macron et
puis un sujet peut-être plus directe qui
est suivi des travailleurs détachés on
va peut-être commencer par part ça avec
vincent couronne à l'ats le directeur
des travailleurs détachés je crois que
c'est de 96 c'est assez simple c'est
pour permettre à des entreprises qui ont
voix
d pour une mission d'être un des
travailleurs dans un pays que ces pc de
travailleurs soient payés pas au niveau
du pays où ils travaillent
mais que leurs cotisations sociales leur
retraite les pays dans leur pays
d'origine mais ça au départ et ça a été
un peu dévoyé
ça a été dévoyé alors mais il serait que
l'idée de départ elle est assez est là
c'est justement parce que en réalité
donc le travailleurs détachés il va
travailler au salaire minimum ou le
salaire convenu dans les dents l'état
d'accueil
mais si les cotisations sociales elles
sont payées dans l'état de départ c'est
pour une bonne raison c'est que le
travers les péchés il prendra sa
retraite là bas il touchera son chômage
là bas et celui-ci tombe malade il sera
soigné là bas alors que ça était logique
tout ça est complètement logique
maintenant si c'est des voiliers
aujourd'hui c'est du fait beaucoup d
entreprises qui l'utilisent au travail
qui sont créées exactement pour profiter
de ça qui crée une simple sur des boîtes
aux lettres en pologne par exemple
bouygues imaginons vos hasard fait ouvre
une boîte aux lettres une succursale en
pologne et puis va en réalité faire
venir les travailleurs polonais depuis
la pologne sur ces chantiers en france
en les voyant en payant en les payant
aux salaires français avec des
conditions pas forcément légal mais en
en payant les cotisations sociales
polonaise parce que ce sont à travers
polonais qui viennent de pologne et qui
sont employés par cette boîte aux
lettres polonaise et sas entreprise
voilà alors en 2014 et une tentative de
renforcer les contrôles donc on a à
maquereau est effectivement tout à fait
oui et donc des hollande sous la
présidence hollande qu'il ya une
nouvelle directive qui a permis de
renforcer les contrôles pour lutter
contre la fraude
bombay sécu c'est a priori pas suffisant
il ya une en 2007 du coup une nouvelle
directive encore pour réviser la
précédente et renforcer encore les
contrôles qui
zynga beauty en 2014 qui marche pas trop
mal mais c'est pas suffisant il ya celle
2016 qui n'a pas abouti parce qu'il ya
tout un tas l'état notamment le bloc
d'europe de l'est et d'europe centrale
qui s'y opposent et l'allemagne au
maquereau essaye de faire un peu de
forcing vis-à-vis alors non pas de la
pologne parce qu'on sait très bien que
la pologne ne soutiendra pas la france
or sur ce point là mais il faut au moins
cassé le bloc de l'est c'est un peu
difficile en plus le danemark qui avait
été voté contre à l'époque alors c'est
moi que c'était deux ans par exemple de
détachement au t2 en voilà et puis faire
en sorte aussi alors si les cotisations
sociales sont toujours payés dans l'état
d'origine
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de faire en
sorte que non seulement le travers les
tâches et touchent le salaire le même
salaire qu'un français en france mais on
inclut aussi les primes les mêmes primes
que en français et tous les autres
avantages coran en français pour très
varié qui va lancer ça parce que sous
prétexte par exemple travailler polonais
qui travaillent en france alors qu'il
est payé comme un français mais sauf
qu'on le paye et un peu moins ils
n'avaient pas droit aux primes et donc
ça diminue beaucoup donné voilà il ya
même une technique qui fait que et ses
travers les tâches et qui arrive en
france et qui n'ont pas de logement
l'entreprise va leur proposer un
logement et va retirer le coût de ce
logement du salaire ils sont pas logés
dans des conditions pas souvent dans des
garages
mais ça aussi ça relève en réalité même
les lacunes de notre propre système de
contrôle en droit du travail
enfin des conditions de travail il n'y a
pas suffisamment de contrôleurs dès que
des entreprises fassent travailler dès
3h et plus il faut plus il en faut plus
un peu surtout les lacunes de l'europe
parce que j'ai il ya quand même beaucoup
moins de problèmes et des travailleurs
détachés qui viennent du danemark
mais ça il ya des 15 science des
différences dans les niveaux de vie
c'est sur wii l'an mille deux cent
cinquante mille français qui sont
détachés ce que je voulais dire c'est
que il faut aussi appeler un chat un
chat c'est parce qu'il ya un véritable
problème avec certaines certains pays
d'europe sera plus lent pas au niveau
le problème et c'est par ailleurs
détacher de l'admr qu'on dit ravi et d'y
aller vers ce voire pas de souci mais je
suis pas sûr que ce soit le niveau de
rémunération qui sera vraiment le
problème parce qu'eux aussi ils viennent
c'est qu'il ya une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre en france sur c'est sûr ça lui
chante est là et qu'on voit qu'on a
besoin d'eux donc la question c'est
maintenant est-ce qu'on contrôle qui
respectent bien le droit et les
entreprises force est de constater elle
ne respecte pas le droit et les font
travailler plus de 48 heures ils n'ont
pas les conditions de travail normales
certaines entreprises pardon non mais il
fallait bien quelqu'un ici un discours
anti entreprises et pas rancunier parce
que pour le coup la france insoumis sur
les réseaux sociaux nous a pas mal à
laisser derrière moi j'aime je suis
menacé l'humour déjà moins une dizaine
fois une scène de jeudi quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave alors sincèrement
une dizaine de fois par les assureurs
les réseaux sociaux la france à celui ci
sont laissés constate aussi qu'il nous
avait lancé markov très intéressant
ah oui c'est vous pouvez voir sur notre
compte twitter la plupart temps où ils
sont anonymes prêts
et donc pour continuer mon discours
mélenchonistes une certaine l'entreprise
du coup effectivement essayé viol le
droit du travail la france est tout
simplement vis-à-vis de ces travailleurs
détachés qui ne parle pas souvent
français qui ont très peu de moyens de
se défendre et qui donc le problème à
mon avis d'abord c'est le contrôle en
france des conditions de travail la
clause molière ça aussi c'est un truc
vaut parler français six fois par les
français sur un chantier
parce que sinon si on comprend pas
comment le type vous dis attention il ya
une brique qui va tomber sur la tête
c'est vrai que c'était pour le cours de
farner que les relations régnèrent sur
ça pour dire que c'était parce qu'il ya
des risques ça soit pas légal de
quelques nouvelles positives a aussi et
c'est pas légal ce n'est pas légal mais
c'est meseta c'est assez simple à mesure
qu'on compte par le feu sur un chantier
juste rappeler quand même que le
l'employeur dans le code du travail a un
devoir de notamment de moins de 2 dans
mes deux formations et donc de vente
formation notamment pour des salariés
qui sont ils les traitent leur faire
savoir lire et écrire et de ce qui s'est
passé ailleurs polonais qui va venir 15
jours il faut que le chef d'entreprise
les faces donner des cours de français a
accéléré pour qu'ils puissent comprendre
blessing la fabrique simplification dans
les allées c'est dit je veux dire on ne
peut pas laisser quelqu'un on en a un
devoir de d'employabilité de nos
salariés qui sont dans notre entreprise
en cdi
c'est un demande de l'employeur de faire
passer ça reste toujours employables
dont on pourrait toujours employables il
faut qu'ils soient formés qui sache lire
il sache écrire et qui sache parler mais
il s'agit donc six français il faut
qu'il appela x men en attendant quinze
jours ces salariés polonais votre
salarié
ces mêmes travailleurs détachés polonais
nous on a un contrat commercial avec une
société commerciale je reviens ou cinq
niveaux sur les activités des
travailleurs détachés
il faut pas la prendre à la légère parce
que c'est une des raisons par exemple du
bras existe un c'est une des raisons du
pré existants c'est comme ça qu'on veut
je dire veut renforcer les contrôles et
c'est parce que c'est une des pierres
d'achoppement pour la construction
européenne
bien sûr le système actuel du
travailleur et hachez ne fonctionne pas
bien il faut clairement le modifier et
pour emmanuel macron politiquement c'est
forcément c'est forcément du bonus pour
lui de lutter contrer cette fin en tout
cas de lutter pour plus de contrôles
façon voilà ça c'est évident que pour
lui c'est une très bonne chose de faire
ça et il y en a besoin et on peut se
passer de l'accord de la pologne pour
pour ferrique cesse de progresser le
développement de la fission il est déjà
la république tchèque et la slovaquie
qui sont il faut
il faut à peu près 8 tous huit ou neuf
états qui s'opposent pour que ça ne
passe pas est bon il ya des gens sages
aurait été qualifié ces majorités qui a
fait quelque chose que ça puisse passer
facilement un mot sur les réformes
institutionnelles
il devrait aussi tiens que l'europe
baisse du taux était d'un budget la part
entière telle ou telle est la
possibilité d'emprunter qui est
peut-être un ministre des finances de la
zone euro
là il va falloir alors vous dans
laquelle elle dit qu'elle serait
d'accord pour les finos mais j'aimais
ils sont pas forcément d'accord entre
eux pour savoir ce que serait et qu'elle
ferait sa vie défile ça oui alors déjà
pour pour écarter tout tout le moins
entendu l'union a déjà un budget il ya
déjà un budget de l'union européenne où
d'ailleurs les fonds de la pac les ailes
régionales ça rate ça c'est le budget
l'union européenne
la nouveauté qui voudrait être qu'on
voudrait introduire c'est de permettre à
union européenne de s'endetter
parce que l'union européenne aujourd'hui
sa ronde il n'y a pas de dette peillon
des dettes
exactement donc au moins l'europe à une
situation financière saine
contrairement par exemple à aux etats
unis qu une situation financière saine
du tout donc à échelle différente on est
dans une sorte d'initiation très très
cher l'identique pardon on est dans une
situation complètement différente et
donc la possibilité qui serait donnée à
l'union d'emprunter sur les marchés
financiers permettrait en fait de
financer par exemple une aide au chômage
une assistance aux pays les plus grands
travaux des grands travaux aussi voilà
tout à fait tous les dix ans pour la
dette devrait mais à partir ou en
emprunte sur les marchés financiers ça
devrait retrouver des ressources pour
rembourser ça veut dire un impôt et qui
dit impôt ça veut dire un parlement qui
vote le pen qui votent l'impôt donc un
ministre de l'économie ou des finances
européens qui va exécuter le prélèvement
de cet impôt etc qui responsable dans ce
parlement tout ça nécessite un
changement important plutôt du côté des
allemands ce système est fait non c'est
juste un type avec une règle comme ça
écrit tape sur les doigts des pays qui
dépassait 1 et 3%
alors si je comprends bien aux bruins en
dix ans il y aura la dette de la france
plus honnête de l'europe voilà pour
l'instant mais ça va être sympa alors
c'est la fin de la vision
je crois que vous vouliez annoncé une
manifestation il ya une conférence
co-organisée par le med a feeling à la
mairie de saint germain en laye le 26
septembre prochain à partir de 18 heures
sur le thème de l'apprentissage donc on
fait une grande soirée sur
l'apprentissage pour montrer que
l'apprentissage ce n'est pas que les
bouchers les boulangers mais que ça peut
être tout à fait un grand pas trop ça va
frapper les enfants n'ont pas fait
d'apprentissage parce qu'il était
brillant n'ont rien on peut être
brillant avec adrian et l'apprentissage
et et voilà donc 26 septembre à saint
germain en laye à partir de 18h à partir
de 18 heures merci pardon vous voudrez
pas je serai pas là je serai à la manif
contre l'ordonnancé versé beaucoup
vasseur de robes mais je trouve le père
cadets merci du positif allemands sont
et jean charles lajoie 10 et à très vite
mois pour un nouveau numéro paf
[Musique]